do you have a lot of home like Cirie and
Alexis at your house that [ __ ] thing
or is that [ __ ] that you you can make
series say Oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you can make seriously [ __ ]
yeah people think I was joking about
that let me show you how to do that
watch this folks here we go what is the
definition what's the definition of
mother come on you piece of [ __ ] change
I'm sorry about that what's the
definition of mother children she has
given birth do you want to hear the next
one yes as a verb it means bring up a
child with care and affection do you
want to hear the last one yes as a verb
it means give birth - oh my god Siri
[ __ ] yeah they did they removed it you
know it oh come on it was funny how did
they leave it in there and then take it
out dude they took out the dead body
woman I remember the first one that's a
crazy one short for [ __ ] yeah it
would say as a you know yeah I bet
Alessa still has it I think I tweeted
what it said what exactly it said yeah I
I did it I did it the day you did it it
took me a couple tries because I didn't
say it right but it ended up doing it it
says as a noun
short form [ __ ] but it could be
a verb as well right yeah if you're
actually a [ __ ] ass here with
mother means and it gives you the
correct definition then it asks you do
you want to hear the next one you say
yes it says as a noun it means short for
[ __ ] yeah I got it right but it
was weird to hear like I heard it I was
like what that's real like imagine if
that's like your mom and she's like
teaching a little kid how to use Siri
like mommy
I know what mom means well we can ask
Siri sweetie we can ask Siri what mother
means okay okay nice to it do you want
to hear the next one okay as a noun
short for a [ __ ] a little kids
like what tell me what do they say do
you know what a serious say if you ask
if Santa's real or some [ __ ] like that
hmm is Santa real I'm going to pretend
you didn't ask that I don't want you to
get a lump of coal this year
Alexa tells you and uses the shares of
Needle Siri are you allowed to swear I
don't have the answer to that is there
something else I can help you with I
just want to know if you stopped using
curse words recently I'm not sure I
understand well earlier in this week I
had asked you what mother means and you
gave me one definition then you had you
said do you wanna hear the next one and
you said as a noun it means short for
mother [ __ ] I just thought that was
weird Syria you sound like a crazy
person like I'm trying to talk to you
about this issue that you and I are
having about communication and what do
you say to me you say that's not nice
well it's not nice for you to say
[ __ ] in front of that little
three-year-old just learning how to talk
well this is the future here's some of
that we have enough us telling you about
this is the future we're gonna be having
arguments with our digital devices like
that
that's a crude like helper I get super
crude helper right
like what Siri could do and not do it's
very crude but this is just like the
iPhone one right maybe they can have
thinking they're absolutely gonna have
some sort of AI that can keep up with
the conversation for sure that's gonna